distinguished members the CEO of Norfolk
Southern Railway was always going to
have a tough day in the Senate
this made it worse touting his company's
safety record on the same day as another
of his trains derailed in Alabama the
fourth in the last few weeks
the worst of those and the reason Alan
Shaw was testifying happened in East
Palestine Ohio a derailment that led to
toxic chemicals Catching Fire officials
later releasing the poisonous fumes into
the air to prevent an explosion but
igniting fears of what it was doing to
People's Health and the health of the
environment on Capitol Hill an apology
and a promise I'm terribly sorry for the
impact this derailment has had
on the folks of that community and yes
it's my personal commitment that Norfolk
Southern's commitment that we're going
to be there for as long as it takes
to help East Palestine Thrive and
recover some Senators say that's not
enough what's right is a family that had
a home worth one hundred thousand
dollars that is now worth fifty thousand
dollars
we'll probably never be able to sell
that home for a hundred thousand again
will you compensate that family for that
loss
scenario I'm committed to do what's
right Aaron Stauffer lives near the
crash site she traveled to Washington
for the hearing she says her town is
still very much afraid the EPA is saying
the water's fine we're hearing
everything's fine you know you can come
home everything's okay but after seeing
that you know Cloud it doesn't seem okay
there's been some dead fish dead animals
found people are getting sick not my
family but some other families are
getting sick so I mean there's just a
general feeling of just uneasy there is
bipartisan legislation here on Capitol
Hill that would mandate increased safety
measures and increase fines on Railway
companies well the CEO said he's not
going to back all of those proposals
that means there's likely going to be a
big fight not just with the industry but
with their powerful lobbyists the bottom
line then it's not clear that America's
Railways or the communities they pass
through are going to be safer anytime
soon pettico Haynes zero on Capitol Hill